[موسيقى]
البذره الاولى للتنظيم الاخوان المسلمين
بالذات كان عام 1937 وكان في
منطقتين مكه المكرمه والمدينه المنوره
الحجاز لم ااه يعني يسجل بشكل رسمي او
يرتبط بشكل رسمي الا في بدايه الثمانينات
الميلاديه لكن هذا لا يعني انه لم يكن
هناك عمل حزبي تنظيمي في المنطقه
فتقسيمات الاخوان همم في المملكه كما
رصدتها انا اولا اخوان الحجاز وتشمل منطقه
مكه المكرمه المدينه المنوره مدينه جده
الطائف ينبع همم تبوك وعسير واجازان
والباحه وبعض منتسبي لتنظيم في المنطقه
الشرقيه يتبعون لاخوان الحجاز او تنظيم
الحجاز حتى في الشرقيه نعم جزء منهم همم
علاقات شخصيه وكذا قد يكون ذهب كم الدراسه
في الجامعات والمنطقه الشرقيه تفرق
المساله في الارتباط هم يرتبطون الكل
يرتبط
بالعام يعني لكن لكل تنظيم مراقب مسؤول
عنه وله مجلس شورى مستقل همم يتعاونوا
فيما بينهم لكن لهم مرجعيه خارج المملكه
ال- همم التنظيم الثاني هو الاخوان الزبير
وهمم من العراق الذين استعدوا الجنسيه
وهؤلاء ارتباطهم
همم تنظيم اخوان الكويت ارتباطهم بالهمي
التنظيم
[موسيقى]
القسم الثالث اليوم اخوان الرياض
مستقل صغير ركز فيها على مناشت معينه
يعني نشاط الجواله في الجامعات وكذا وبقي
التنظيم الرئيسي
دكتور عفوا الاسماء يعني
ذكرت رموز همم لانه ليس من المهم ان نرصد
الفكر والحركه يعني همم
انشقت عن المجموعه فاصبح تنظيم الرياض
تنظيم بيننا يعني ال- همم التنظيم الخامس
اللي هو الاخوان الشرقيه
وهؤلاء همم يعني همم يعني مستقلون في
تنظيم مستقل همم مرتبط ايضا تنظيميا هرميا
باخوان الكويت كان او نشاط الاخوان
التنظيم نعم بهذه التنظيمات الخمسه همم ما
بين عام 1967 الى عام 1991 كانت قواعدهم
كبيره ومكتسحه
[موسيقى]